90 هو مغير اللعبة 90
الآن أنت تأمل أن يكون لديك أداة
في حربك ضد هذا الوباء
يمكن أن تكون فعالة بشكل كبير
آه كم من الوقت
ستستمر هذه الحماية هو شيء
لا
نعرفه الآن ولكنه جزء
من هدف  في الدراسة ،
سنتابع 44000
شخصًا تلقوا أنهم جزء
من هذه
الدراسة لمدة عامين ، وخلال هذه
المتابعة من الواضح
أننا سننظر أيضًا في
متانة الاستجابات المناعية ،
لذلك هناك بضع نقاط فقط
لشرح  قليلاً أولاً من كل
90 حماية مرة أخرى بغض النظر عن كيفية
قصها ، فهذه أخبار رائعة
وأعتقد أن أحد الأسئلة الكبيرة هو 90
فعالاً في منع الأشخاص من
الإصابة
بالعدوى ، كما أنه فعال 90 أيضًا في منع
الأشخاص من الإصابة بمرض خطير
مما يعني أنك تعرف ذلك  يمنع
العدوى الخفيفة أو الأكثر اعتدالًا
أو يمنع
العدوى الخطيرة التي تؤدي إلى الإصابة بمرض كوفا الخطير ،
فهو لا يعرف أنه لم يكن يعرف حقًا
الإجابة على ذلك وسنقوم بذلك.  للحصول
على
فكرة أفضل عندما تكون البيانات غير معماة ،
تعرف أيضًا أن هذا السؤال الذي
تحدثنا عنه مرات عديدة في برنامجك إلى
متى يستمر بشكل
صحيح ، هل نعرف ما إذا كان شخص
ما مصابًا أو قد يكون لديهم مناعة
لعدة أشهر
كان لا يزال  إنها علامة استفهام قليلاً ،
ماذا عن
اللقاح هل سيكون هذا مثل شيء سنوي
من طلقتين
مرة أخرى لا يعرف أنه يقول
إنهم سيتابعون هؤلاء المرضى
لبضع سنوات مرة أخرى 90
فعالاً على الرغم من التغييرات  إنه ليس مثل
لقاح الإنفلونزا الذي يتراوح من 30 إلى 50 ،
هذا أقرب إلى الحصبة حيث
تبدأ حقًا في
دفع الفيروس بعيدًا تمامًا ومن المحتمل
أن ننتظر ونرى
سانجاي أريد أن أتناول لقمة أخرى
هنا من مقابلتك معه و
كان هذا رائعًا وهذا يتعلق بالوقت
الذي يحدث فيه كل ذلك عندما أه سوف
يرتفع العرض إلى النقطة التي
يمكن أن يحصل عليها المزيد من الأمريكيين ،
ونعتقد أننا
في وضع جيد للحصول على ما يصل إلى 50
مليون جرعة هذا العام  r
عالميًا وأعتقد
أننا في وضع جيد جدًا للحصول
على 1.3 مليار جرعة على
مستوى العالم سانجاي ، ماذا
تعني هذه الأرقام ، حسنًا ، فهذه أيضًا أرقام أعلى بكثير
مما كنت عليه هنا ، لقد كنا
نتتبع هذا لبعض الوقت كنا نظن
ذلك  في الولايات المتحدة
ربما مئات الآلاف من الجرعات
أه تم تصنيعها نوعًا ما في خطر
في هذه المرحلة
أه قال السيد بورلز إنها
بالملايين ثم في الولايات المتحدة
وحدها
قال إنه سيكون هناك عشرات الملايين من
الجرعات المتاحة في  الولايات المتحدة
،
هناك ثلاثة على الأقل من
مواقع التصنيع ومواقع التوزيع هذه
وهي رائعة جدًا في
كالامازو ميشيغان على سبيل المثال
ملعب كرة قدم بقيمة ثلاجات
الآن حيث بدأوا في
تخزين هذا اللقاح
بشكل أساسي وهم ذاهبون إلى  ابدأ في
توزيعه ولكن لديهم أيضًا
منشأة أخرى أعتقد أنه قال إنه
كان في ألمانيا أو في بلجيكا ، ولا أستطيع أن
أتذكر
المكان الذي سيتم توزيعه فيه بالفعل
بالتفكير بجدية هناك
لبقية العالم بشكل أساسي ،
أعني أنك تعلم في النهاية أنه يعتقد أنه يعتقد أن هناك
مليار جرعة في عام 2021
مما يعني 650 مليون شخص
مرة أخرى ، هذا
لقاح من طلقة إلى اثنتين ، لذلك
كان هناك الكثير مما يحدث على ما أعتقد
ما يعنيه ذلك فيما يتعلق
بتصنيع هذا اللقاح حتى قبل أن يكون
هناك أي نوع من إذن الاستخدام الطارئ
ناهيك عن الموافقة ، فهذه
أخبار جيدة بمعنى
أنه سيكون متاحًا بشكل أسرع
وأعتقد أنه لا يزال للأشخاص في هذا البلد
الذين يفكرون في
هذا  ما زلنا نتحدث عن فصل الربيع
قبل أن يتوفر هذا اللقاح ،
ونسمع أيضًا أنه سيكون مجانيًا ،
وسألتهم على وجه التحديد عن شخص
يراقب ، فقلت إنهم يريدون هذا اللقاح
كم سيكلفهم ،
قال إن هذا اللقاح الذي يخططون له
جعله متاحًا مجانًا لأن
الحكومة كانت تشتري هذا وتخطط
للوصول إلى أكبر قدر ممكن من اللقاح
خلال الأشهر العديدة القادمة